hey 42 here we've all been there you've
just won the lottery and you're kicking
back in your hot tub indulging in your
favorite beverage then all of a sudden
it's gone your alarm clock rudely
awakened you and you come back to the
sudden realization that your life is
considerably less glamorous than in your
dreams Oh bollocks but then something
strange happens five minutes passes by
and you've forgotten most of if not all
of your dream and that's if you're lucky
sometimes we have dreams we're not even
aware of because we can't remember even
having them in the first place
after we've awoken why is this why do we
so easily forget our dreams let's find
out the brain is the last major mystery
of the human body there are so many
aspects of the brain that continuously
baffled scientists and one of those is
sleep scientists aren't even 100% sure
why we even need sleep so when it comes
to understanding dreams we're still very
much in the dark
we have many theories of course one of
the more popular theories is that when
we sleep our brains are filtering
through the day's memories and deciding
which ones are important enough to keep
permanently and which to ditch
scientists think dreams are a visual
representation of this process based on
that theory it makes sense that in order
to understand dreams further we should
study the two parts of the brain that
are largely responsible for processing
memories those are the hippocampus and
the neocortex and that's exactly what
researchers at the California Institute
of Technology did first let's talk about
the hippocampus which you may be
surprised to know it's not a college
campus for hippos it's actually named
after its resemblance to a seahorse this
is the part of our brain where memories
are formed
however it's fought that during sleep
these memories get transferred to the
outer layer of our brain then
go cortex where they are permanently
stored think of it like a digital camera
the hippocampus is the camera's sensor
the neocortex is the memory for a memory
to be transferred from the hippocampus
to the neocortex these two parts of the
brain have to be connected via neurons
which are responsible for transmitting
information around our brains if your
brain where the Internet then the
neurons will be the rootless the
hippocampus and the neocortex do this by
firing electrical signals from the
neurons at exactly the same time several
times per second imagine the two parts
of your brain are having a conversation
about the events of the day
ie your memories when they both fire
their neurons at the same time and they
are in sync we know they are
communicating with each other scientists
call it numeral chatter scientists at
Caltech use brand new technology to
listen in to these two parts of the
brain in rats whilst they were sleeping
they found that whilst the rats were in
a stage of the sleep cycle known as slow
wave sleep more commonly referred to as
deep sleep the hippocampus and the
neocortex were perfectly in sync their
neurons were firing at the same time
from this we can presume that the two
parts of the brain were talking to each
other and memories were being recorded
but here's where dreams come in during
the slow wave sleep phase we don't have
any dreams this is known as a dreamless
sleep State
the researchers then did the same thing
whilst a rats were in the rapid eye
movement or REM sleep stage what they
observed once and for all answered why
we have a hard time remembering our
dreams during the REM sleep stage the
hippocampus and neocortex were still
firing their new runs but not at the
same time they were no longer in sync
she put it in other words they were
still having conversations but not with
each other
this means during REM sleep memories
don't get recorded - our brains databank
the neocortex and REM sleep just happens
to be when the majority of our dreams
occur
so the memories of our dreams are still
being created they're just not being
stored permanently we remember only very
faint aspects of our dreams because very
occasionally the neurons might by chance
fire at the same time but the majority
of the time they don't some people
believe this is because dreams are
non-essential to life then no more than
a byproduct of the creation of new
memories during our sleep so what's the
point in remembering them they don't
serve a purpose but for whatever reason
we don't remember our dreams simply
because during a certain stage of our
sleep two very important parts of our
brain which are both responsible for
memory don't get on with each other very
well to be honest it's probably for the
best some of the weirder stuff we do in
our dreams is definitely best forgotten
find to the view subscribe for more
thoughty2